the Joe Rogan experience and so so in
that sense people that are genuine and
have ideas like Andrew yang is another
one
he has like a ridiculous number of ideas
I'm a few seen like he thinks all cops
should be purple belt in jujitsu I like
it my go Andrew yeah there's a million
other ideas he sees well he's a genius I
mean he's a brilliant guy and he's an
entrepreneur so he comes at this stuff
from a different angle yeah you know
he's open-minded like I yes I well I
disagree with him on his evaluation of
the state of artificial intelligence and
automation in terms of its capabilities
and having an impact on the economy you
don't think it's gonna be as much of a
deal as he thinks it is I am the
timescale that he thinks it is but I
also want to be careful sort of
commenting on that because I think for
him it's a tool to describe the concerns
the suffering that people go through in
terms of in terms of losing their job
like the the pain that people are
feeling throughout the country it's a
it's like a mechanism he uses to talk to
people about the future in that you know
there are people that are well off like
the different tech companies that should
also contribute to investing in our
community I mean the specifics I want to
kind of sit back and relax a little bit
it's like when you watch a sci-fi movie
and the details are all really bad I
want to just mention of disbelief or
whatever and enjoy the movie in the same
way the stuff he says about AI he's not
very knowledgeable about AI and
automation so it's a little it touches
me a little bit the wrong way engine
we're not as far along the the
transformative effects of artificial
intelligence in terms of replacing
humans in trucking autonomous vehicles
something I know a couple things about
is not going to be as you know I could
speak relatively confidently the the
revolution in autonomous vehicles would
be more gradual than Andrew is
describing but that's okay there's a
million other ideas and ubi nevertheless
the university basic income was some
kind of support structure of that kind
nevertheless could be a very good idea
for people that lose their job for
people to be more
while in terms of going for one type of
job - another type of job so continually
learning through our life it's just that
artificial intelligence in this case I
don't think will be the enemy it'd be
there could be other things that are a
little bit sort of neighbours of
artificial intelligence which is sort of
the software world eating up some of the
mechanization of factors and so on you
know maybe maybe the the fact that you
know the kind of way that Tesla and Elon
Musk are approaching the design and
engineering of vehicles that are a
little bit more software centric will
change will sort of move some of the job
from Detroit Michigan in terms of cars
to the Silicon Valley unnecessary
location wise but sort of a different
type of person would need to be hired to
work on cars a little bit more software
engineering software centric versus the
sort of hardcore mechanical engineers
more sort of you know tradition called
car guys you know gals right yeah so
that there will be some job replacement
so on but it's not this artificial
intelligence trucks will completely
replace a job and in case of trucks you
know that it's not there's a lot of
complicated aspects about the impact of
automation sort of trucking jobs there's
actually a lot of need for jobs like
there's not the truck that that job
there's already people leaving that job
sector it's a really difficult job it
doesn't pay as well as it should it's
really difficult to train people and so
on so the the impact that he talks about
in terms of AI is a little bit of
exaggerated but like I said a million
really good ideas he's open-minded so
the in terms of I think the nice role of
a president is to have ideas like the
purple belt one to inspire people and
inspire Congress to soon implement some
of those ideas and be open-minded and
not take yourself seriously enough to
think that you know all the right
answers
Andrew yang Bernie is like that
although bernie is like 78 years old so
yeah he's getting up there yeah look at
president Tulsi when he kicks the bucket
you know what I didn't really well yeah
that's so I think Hillary Clinton
endorsed Bernie and Tulsi Gabbard for
president reverse endorsement
accidentally yeah well yeah if I say
it's just such a petty thing to say that
no one likes Bernie I come on Lady
this is you're in the twilight of your
life I think she's really aware of the
fact that if she says something like
that people are gonna like Bernie more I
think it's an endorsement I don't think
she has any idea of that I think she's
super insulated I don't I don't think
she I think she thinks that she can
actually hamstring him by saying
something like that and she doesn't
understand that it just makes people
realize that the things that they say
about her correct yeah negative credit
ruling you gave her credit for killing
upstate
I was joking I think she did I think
somebody did it I don't know who it was
maybe some scientist character maybe
he's still alive it could be doesn't any
Bravo thanks man Eddie Bravo thinks he's
in like Dominican Republic somewhere
eating bananas and drinking mai tais
it's a conspiracy on a conspiracy
yeah well Eddie's always like that he's
many levels deep he plays for DHS when
it comes to conspiracy do you think that
Andrew yang is off but ultimately will
be correct in terms of the automation
timeline do you think that maybe he
doesn't know clearly as much as you know
about automation and artificial
intelligence but do you think that it's
possible that you know I think he's
looking at a timeline I think he was
thinking within the next 10 years right
millions and millions of jobs gonna be
replaced do you think that it's more
like 20 years or 30 years it's still
something exact concern so the timeline
of course nobody knows but I think the
timeline is much the time skills is more
stretched out so 20-30 years and it will
continue they'll be there'll be certain
key revolutions and those revolutions
it's a suit it's an incorrect word to
use but they'll be stretched out over
time I think that autonomous vehicle
revolution is something to achieve a
scale of millions of vehicles that are
fully autonomously
navigating our streets I think is 20 30
years away mm-hmm and it won't be like
all of a sudden it'll be gradual
there'll be people like the form of
Google self-driving car way moe company
who's doing a lot of testing now
incredible engineer I've visited them
for a day you'll be expanding their
efforts slowly they're doing also way
more trucks autonomous trucking already
deploying them in Texas I think and then
of course Tesla who's this year going to
approach a million vehicles and they're
trying to achieve full strength
self-driving capability and but that's
going to be gradual
[Applause]